the best way to develop a strong neck
safely is to take a plate and start
really light lie on a bench stabilize
yourself by putting one arm down
probably start with a five or a 10lb
plate wrapped in a towel so you don't
end up with an imprint of the five or 10
on the side of your head and then put
that plate and then you're just going to
go from neutral position which is your
head essentially straight up and down
but you're lying on your side to just
about maybe 30 or 45° this is important
keep your tongue on the roof of your
mouth your jaw shut so that your jaw are
moving around because some people do
neck work and then they'll get clicking
of the jaw they get pain in the ear and
you're not going to failure you're not
training really heavy 10 to 25
repetition range three sets yeah three
sets and then the other side I can do
five or six reps on each side with a
45lb plate you're kidding me that's 20
kilos